I'm Julia signal I'm a developer at
anaconda I work on the PI vis ecosystem
which is this umbrella of tools that
encompasses bouquet and also some
higher-level libraries that wrap bokeh
and also can render other with other
backends like my pot lid so I'm going to
be running through this example that
builds up to this this dashboard that
I've shown here statically so it will
just be stepping through that in
notebooks so if you want to follow along
I've created a binder link I don't know
how well that'll work it's a pretty big
environment but yeah you can find out my
github app I did at UC 2018 alright so
I'm just gonna jump right in okay so
just just to get situated a little bit I
know you guys have been in visualization
talks all morning but what do we want
out of visualization so we want to be
able to explore our data and see
patterns we're gonna identify bad data
maybe develop intuition about how our
models work or how our systems work and
we want to be able to present our data
to other people share it tell a story
and then so what tools what do our tools
need to be to to facilitate those aims
so we want interactivity you want to be
able to zoom in and out we render on
user input maybe draw on pot to annotate
when we want or we want to salt our work
to be reproducible so we want to be able
to look at the same data again and if in
a year so we want our our environment to
be well defined and then we want to may
be able to look at the new different
data and then we want it to be shareable
so we want to be able to deploy
dashboard and share notebook with
environment specification with other
people so they can reproduce the work
themselves so we're going to be looking
at this data set which is bird migration
data it's was collected by citizen
scientists
of different species in the lat/long and
day of year and then it was compiled by
these scientists that I've cited here
and into the centroid of a particular
species at each day of the year so the
data is organized this all-night github
repo it's organized in CSV files where
each file is a particular species and
each row is a day of the year with lat
long as the columns so we're going to be
loading this data and using intake you
don't need to use intake but it's just a
convenient way to do this is that big
enough people can see it yeah okay
so you can just do intake open csv and
use a format string for a Python and
you'll load in all your data so we have
all the data here and that's just the
head but you can look at the species
column and see that there's a 117
different types of species and some of
them have all the days of the year so
we're going to be working towards a
dashboard that looks like this you saw a
screenshot of it how it ended up in the
end but this is where I started I wanted
to create something like this so just to
orient yourselves that's what we're
going towards okay
actually that might not work well
somebody's notebooks takes a little bit
so we're gonna start by exploring our
data using HB plot on this night take a
minute to load it's a kind of big
notebook because I've already rendered
it but HB plot is a new library or a
relatively new library that we've been
developing that you it it is very
similar to the dot plot notation if
you're familiar with if use pandas
dataframes or a lot of other data sets
support it like X or a objects so we're
going to be and instead of returning a
matplotlib object it returns a howl of
use object which we can we're going to
render in Bocca in this case but you
wouldn't have to so you can just import
hv plot like this and then it provides
the and then we'll be able to access it
right from our pandas object so here we
have our data frame of birds and we're
just plotting the points of lat on and
so this is an interactive plot so we can
zoom in and it'll be render and we can
hover and it has all the interactivity
that you expect and ok you'll notice
that it's kind of hard to see all those
dots there are situated on top of each
other so we can use data shade which is
a another library that's used to
transform data so that we are only
rendering the count per pixel of birds
so you can sort of just see more
structure in this but still not quite
what we want we would want to be want to
use color more effectively so we can
color by day of the year I've got so
each of this is a circular color map so
that it it represents the data better
since this is you know 0 is 366 so this
is starting to get most of our
information on this one pot which is
kind of cool
so the only thing that's missing is
which species is which
so by adding hover we now have our whole
data set represented in this one pod so
this is a good HB plot allows us to do
these really straightforward data
analysis and get a lot of depth on our
data pretty quickly and you can just
sort of iterate over it so to more
effectively look at our whole data set
we might want might want to split out
different species and look at them
individually so we're gonna look at
grouping next so you can group bys we're
gonna group by species first so now we
get this toggle and we can or this
drop-down and you can select different
species
you're on this cell and you can select
different species and you'll see that it
appears in the pot and you still get all
the interactivity and the hover but now
we can just look at a particular species
and see the migration pattern so what
this looks like in is how it's actually
a hollow views object this P here that
I've defined I've set to the output of
the HV plot and it's a dynamic mapping
of species to points so this might look
a little weird but if you are interested
we'll get into that more later even if
you're not interested we'll get into it
more so we can inspect just one bird the
same way that you use a dictionary so if
you're just interested in the
connecticut war boy we can use that same
p that we defined above and use it since
it's a mapping we can just get one
particular bird from it so you'll notice
in this data that there's a gap I'm
gonna make this bigger that there's a
gap between day 77 and day 104 so we can
do a linear and that's just a missing
data but we know where the bird was
right like the bird was somewhere in
here so we can just do a linear
interpolation
and so we'll just do that little
cleaning and then we can look at the
Connecticut Warbler again and it's
cleaned up such as for our future
analysis to make things better so now we
can combine some pots so this is a
slightly weird thing about how of use
sometimes people get confused but you
can use the plus operator to create
layouts of pots that are linked and you
can use the times operator which you'll
see you later - to create overlays so
these pots this is a particular species
so as you toggle species both those
plots are going to change and then you
can also do things like zooming and
they'll both change as well so that's
that's the end of the HV plot section
and now we're going to move on to
talking about pure hall of use okay so
how abuse is all based around this idea
that you should you should annotate your
data and then allow it to display itself
so it sets up this concept of a data set
that's slightly that has a little extra
metadata than we normally would put on a
data set so we have our data frame from
pandas and then we're adding in this
definition of the key dimensions and the
value dimensions so that allows us to
explain what are what are columns mean
semantically and so you can see that
when you print it out it looks you can
see that the key dimensions of the RAI
dimensions are very clearly separated
and then we still have our data in there
so it's just an extra layer of metadata
that allows us to then make pots very
quickly so for visualizing our data we
can now take that data set and we can
just send it to points there's some
styling up here which you don't need to
worry about right now but just to make
it a little
bigger so we'll send it right to points
and then we can do the same we can also
send it to different kinds of plots so
we have this PE object now and we can
look at the density instead by taking
the bird data set that we define and we
can make hex tiles so we can see some
more structure of counts and so you can
make different types of pots this way
you can also do a lot of styling so
we're gonna set a custom color map to
get the max among visual difference
between the species and so I'm using
grass P colors but it's not very
important
it's just colors that are maximally
visually different and I'm gonna set
that to the speaking so you can see that
each species now has a different color
and you can so the the styling is can be
controlled up here we're gonna see a
different way of doing it later but you
can notice that P is the same P that we
were talking about before so and all of
us change is the way that I was rendered
in this one cell so that's kind of an
important thing about call of use is
that the data is kept separate from the
rendering so you have you say where the
data is like and how you're gonna
interact with it and then you see how
you want to see it essentially so we're
gonna do some grouping so we can group
by day here and this probably shouldn't
over you on that because it might take a
minute so this is getting the the
rendering options are getting a little
more intense but basically I've added
some different bouquet tools and you can
see now that if you dry this you can see
all the different days for all the
different birds and if you hover on
these particular birds you'll get some
more information you can also select and
then do the dragging to see where they
go so we'll be doing more of that but so
this makes
holomap which is similar to a dynamic
map and so we can still access each item
in that in that grouping of plots so
let's add another layer to the data so
we're gonna be adding temperature data
to see we the hypothesis is that but
it's not great because of temperature so
we'll be looking at putting a global
climate model underneath the birds to
look at the temperature where they are
so we're gonna be using x-ray you can
just download directly or you can just
call this data URL directly um I was
sitting I mean so I down a little okely
so this is just an import using x-ray
this the time is in a strange format
because it's the long term mean air
temperature so it doesn't have a year
associated with it it's kind of a weird
thing so I just set it today integer day
and then we can use HV pot to look at it
so this is this is what we get if we
just use use the data set and plot X
versus Y using hv plot so we can toggle
these things so this is a pressure level
and this is the day and so you can sort
of see that you get more I didn't
originally fully understand what the
pressure level was so but you can see
that you have my definition of
continents at higher level so as surface
pressure as I found out so we're going
to use a thousand millibars for four
hours so we can just for the rest of our
analysis so we can just select that that
one level this is just using x-ray
select notation and so now we have our
our temperature layer that we can add to
our Birds so just a note that this is a
dynamic map there's a slight difference
between a hollow map and a dynamic map
all the maps are pre computed
so you make all your pots ahead of time
and that's what how abuse does by
default HP plot by default does a
dynamic map so you don't have to pre
compute everything so it just computes
on-the-fly so this will only work in a
running notebook it won't work in a
static website unless you pre compute so
we can see that the keys on this if we
so the keys are only going to be the
ones just to further indicate that it's
a dynamic map we're only going to have
the keys that we've slid to essentially
so if we do this again we only have day
one but if we slide it around a little
don't get more keys so we just have the
ones we've only computed the ones that
we've needed essentially since they're
on the same since the bird plot and the
airport are on the same are both hall of
use objects even though one was created
using HV plot one was created using hall
of use we can put them on the same plot
and do an overlay so this is the time
notation to do an overlay but this
doesn't quite work because they're on
different these two data sets or have
different longitude conventions so the
birds are using negative for the Western
Hemisphere and the global climate model
is just counting up from 0 to 360 so
this is a good time to jump into how G
of use out of hall of use so geo views
is just a wrapper around it's just a
super set of hollow use but adds extra
metadata that is good for geo contexts
so we can import it the same way we were
doing with Howell use and I had some
extra metadata so one of the important
things that we're going to add is the
coordinate reference system which just
says how the data are what the data
with what the XY coordinates are so this
is using Carter pi so plate Kure just
means that on so this is our data set
now as a geo views object it looks very
similar to the hall of use and now we
can just automatically plot the data so
we're going to use do show the points
data so it's all the same but now we can
overlay geo features on top of our data
and in this case we've just overlaid the
coastline of North America and South
America and but you'll see that it
doesn't it doesn't set well okay so you
can look the points are the same as they
were in the hall views we can do
grouping the same way we did in hall of
use
I just set dynamic to true to make it
faster so we can do some grouping and
you'll see that only the birds we render
so this is starting to look good but
it's out of bounds because since it
hasn't pre computed all the pots it
doesn't know what the balance should be
so we can set those explicitly and use
tiles underneath and we start starts
looking more we want our dashboard to
look and this is um so here I've set
options directly on the object so that I
can save it so this is a instead of
using cell magic so that I was doing
before we can use these options directly
on the object which might look familiar
to more familiar to people so you can
zoom in and since it styles it we render
so there's a lot you can do with this
kind of data like this is a good way to
explore your data especially geo data
you can do the same thing directly in HV
pot if you don't want to mess around
with hall of use too much
so you can just directly just from
straight from the data frame you can
plot it if you just set geo to true
it'll it'll guess the coordinate
reference system you can also set it
explicitly so this is the same plot but
use created using HP plot so we can add
the other layer again which is the
temperature data so this is now
temperature data and the birds and the
coastline and starting to look pretty
good you'll notice that the rendering is
a little slower when you when you scroll
just because it's a lot of information
to be sending to the browser so the last
thing we're going to do and I'll just
stay right in the notebook for this
rather than doing the slides I think it
gets a little confusing is create a
panel let me pump that up we're gonna
use panel to create a dashboard that's
just that this is just the voting in the
data that we have been building up so
this is the dashboard we're trying to
build so just to go through it in a
little detail there's a slider for day
of year there's um the species drop-down
to select there's a base layer of of
whether you want your temperature data
on or not there's a little running table
that updates and then there's this time
series down here that shows various
features against day of the year
and then there's a map that that
responds to these toggles and also you
can select from the map and get changes
to your other stuff so the first thing
that we're doing so we're using panel
for this which is a fairly new library
but it works with a variety of different
types of objects you don't have to use
how I've used objects anything that can
display in HTML will work so so first
we're going to create a widget so this
is this I've set the options I set the
size and then you can select from
this and so get this the value so you
can select different things and the
value changes down here so this is looks
like every other widget that you've seen
and then we're going to create a player
widget which is for a day of year and
then we can look at that how that
changes I set the step to more than one
just so we don't have to render every
single day and then the toggle to toggle
on or off air temperature this is pretty
straightforward
so now we're going to capture the
streams from those widgets so we can use
them in our dynamic maps so this is this
is a little wonky err but bear with me
um so you set up you set up your stream
and then just a sanity check what you
want is a function that has the stream
as a argument and then you can use it to
dine to generate a dynamic map using
hollow views so to see how that works
this is just a really simple plot of
text that shows the different species
that you've clicked on you can see as
you click around that updates as you
select different species so that's just
to understand what's going on here a
little bit so we'll make a reset button
for a thing and if you click the reset
button everything on sets so that's just
some little component parts so we've
that we've set up now we're going to
construct the plots so these are all
going to be the same as we have been
building up to in our other notebooks
and so we're going to set up a bird's
plot which is just the birds points with
tiles underneath so that's this one same
as we've been seeing and then we're
going to set instead of having the
instead of using this toggle here or
this slider here we're going to set it
the the stream to be the the day stream
from above so we can get it
the slider object so now we have this
now we are using a panel dot row to
create a row of different things so we
have a we have our birds with our tiles
underneath and then we have a slider so
you'll see that this now responds this
it's a little slow this just the player
is slow but it responds to the output
from this this this widgets stream here
it also still responds to this so it's
it's just responsible things um but it
doesn't we don't really want to look at
this anymore this slider we just want
the player so we can if we print row we
can see that every item in it has an
index so we can just select which ones
we want by indexing so we don't want
this one but we do want these other two
so we can just we can just control which
ones we get that way so now we'll add in
another layer so I just was sub setting
down to the area of interest to the
region of interest and then we can do a
group by same as we did above or as soon
as we did in the other notebook and
we've got so we've got our our
temperature layout here and then we can
you'll notice that as we talk around the
temperature is hopping in the color bar
is hopping so we don't really want that
so we can fix it
by looking at the min and Max and
picking something similar and setting
that to the range of the temperature and
then the last thing is just adding a
toggle to turn the temperature on and
off so when is so I'm setting the fill
of the temperature layer to zero when
the when this is untold' okay so we're
building up the little parts
and you can see the row there too just
to check your intuition about what's
going on and then at this point I
realize that it's kind of hard to see
these birds sometimes so I added a
highlight toggle which just adds a white
line around all the birds so the next
thing is to do a little more computation
so we want the we want to populate the
table in our dashboard with speed of the
bird at any particular day and temper
and temperature so the speed is easy to
is straightforward to calculate um you
just use pipe Rajan you can calculate
the distance between for a given species
from day to day so this is kilometers
per day and then you can also set up and
then we'll set up a little time series
to show the latitude and the speed
versus day year so I'll just show you
what this looks like so this is a
function that accepts species and a y
variable and it outputs a plot so if you
give it a list of species and a variable
then it'll just do it so it does Latin
speed and then we can set up a dynamic
map using the the time series function
and the streams the specie streams which
is the species that you've selected so
now we can see almost show another panel
object so you can use markdown right in
panel two to just write some context and
this is how you can see the the speed
plot and the plot are updating as I
select different things
the next thing so just spend out column
to see what it looks like so then we'll
set up the table so we're going to set
up the temperature calculation which is
gonna pick the nearest use it this is
x-ray stuff but it's just using the
nearest value for the temperature for a
given lat lawn and day so so if you have
you passing the dataset and you pass in
a particular row of the data which is
one bird at one day and you get the
temperature so we'll set up a little
table so this should start to look
familiar maybe that this is a function
that accepts two different values that
were going to be toggling between and
sliding around and then the just to
check what the function looks like we
can input some starter values and then
we'll create a dynamic map from that and
the last thing we need to do is to hook
up the map selector to the multi
selector so the multi selector is the
species options so we're going to set it
so that every time you click on the map
and select a particular subset of birds
that updates the species in the list and
then this is just putting the pieces
together so we're going to make this out
of columns and rows and panel and I just
kind of fiddled with it until it looked
good but it's only using the things that
we've created already in this notebook
and then this just sets up the object
and names it and then we're going to add
this dot servable on it so that we can
serve it from outside the notebook so
since we've already been messing with
these selectors we have those values but
we can reset and then you'll see that we
have this dashboard which doesn't quite
fit on my screen blown up like this but
you can start it going and speed it up
and you can select one thing I didn't
quite get to hook up was selecting from
here and having effect the plot but you
can select from the plot and it row
update these so that's like for their
work to be done
but you can see the birds moving about
and you can see these table values are
updating that's a little too fast and
then you can toggle between the speed
and the latitude and longitude so the
last thing I wanted to show you guys is
that well this is what it looks like
printed out so it'll gets a little
gnarly but you can serve this directly
from the CLI from the notebook you can
also separate it out into a dot pie file
and just put the relevant parts because
there's a lot of stuff in here that's
not needed a lot of like looking at
things as we go so I can I mean cause
this to convince you that I'm really
doing it so you can just serve the
notebook and it's going to go to this
particular location which I will refresh
to prove that it went and I also have
these notebooks too deployed on anaconda
Enterprise at those bit ly links which I
can give you again at the end if you
want to like just play with it so those
are externally available links so this
is our dashboard
maybe we'll shrink it down so it fits
and so you can see that's this is from
our notebook we're just serving that
directly so it might not be the best way
to store your code long term but if you
just want to if you have the notebook
made and you just want to show it to
people it has all the same functionality
and it's this isn't this is not static
this is like being you know this is
anything but yeah and you can also just
create the this is what they looked like
when I slimmed them down a little so
this is the app top I just with the
functions and the plots and the widgets
and stuff
and just creating the dashboard so I
also that one's a zooms a little laggy
so I also made one without
temperature that's a little more
pleasing I think that just makes the
birds go a little it doesn't have as
much like so that's what I wanted to
show you guys if you are interested in
learning more about this you should go
to private org there's a lot of
tutorials and stuff and it'll step you
through in more detail hopefully you got
a taste anyone have questions ya know so
the question was does all the data gets
sent at once when you go to dashboard
static one yes I think so
um but this is not that so this is a
dynamic one so it's got a running Python
instance in the background the question
is can we support images and hover plots
for bouquet so when is so when you hover
you have a pot that shows up I'm not
sure if that's supported directly so the
HP pot is meant to be like shortcuts
essentially so you can get places
quickly and then you can tweak it
because you have a Hall of user object
so it doesn't it doesn't add a lot of
new functionality like it's not going to
do anything that pokey can't do it's
just easier to do what bouquet can do
yeah yeah mm-hmm yeah Oh a question yeah
the question was does panel serve run a
bogie server I mean yes it does all
right yeah when you were doing the group
into the HP switch switch this
wide-scale I assume you can fix the XY
scale
ah yes you can fix XY scale
okay that's it Thanks
[Applause]